SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Eres una demandaron.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No, no hablo.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No, no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y no me hables desarrollar lo que es Okay ahorita, ¿no?
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y a
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Alonge cómo le va un día inge para hacer para añadir otro participante.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Buen día, buen día inge para añadir otro participante en la audiencia virtual, me escucha
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: para añadir otro participante de la audiencia virtual. Dije, por favor.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: me escuchas su número, otro el 726. Siete, 9, 7
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: a la y hasta otra.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y ahora yo ahí le viene el enlace doctora.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: pero falta el demandado no no está, no e'tá doctora, me sabe doctor.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Si no lo llevaron, no hay nadie. Solamente estamos el doctor y yo nomás a otro.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: no es que tenía que pasarme. Tenía que pasarme el número de teléfono para que yo le envié el link del centro penitenciario.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: el doctor. El eso sí lo han trasladado
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: ya, pero el número de teléfono ya no es suficiente. Sí, ya se lo mandé. Yo mismo.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: a la señora de manera diligente, así como lo he hecho yo sin llegar a Audiencia: rapidísimo.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: ¿no? Pero tiene que buscar el contacto doctor no lo llevan.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: iban a preguntar y combinar o algo que tenemos incluida es esa.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y no
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: alguien ha multiplicado parte del tiempo.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: ya no vean. Bueno, ya
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: dentro del proceso de asistencia familiar que sigue a la letra.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No, pero porque tienen que mandarme el el número para que yo los invite entonces.
Alfredo Román Roca: Encuentras en.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Encuentra presente el demandado.
Alfredo Román Roca: El señor Johan Klassen Wailer.
Alfredo Román Roca: Entonces lo hicimos por Comisión.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Ya rutina de que las chicas.
Alfredo Román Roca: Ninguna que.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y en.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el quisiera saber la ubicación de su domicilio real y y.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y en por qué.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y en.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Sí, ya.
Alfredo Román Roca: En la provincia.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De la.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Principio, 4, comunidad, 5.
Alfredo Román Roca: Barrio, Señor barrio de Salón, Centro.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Shannon está.
Alfredo Román Roca: No, no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Perdón, comunidad 5 de junio más válido centro del centro. Salud. Salud.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De acuerdo?
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y no muy bien.
Alfredo Román Roca: Tendencias.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De la.
Alfredo Román Roca: La de.
Alfredo Román Roca: Que en.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En su pretensión de proteger el.
Alfredo Román Roca: Cáncer.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: A 2 000.
Alfredo Román Roca: No.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y serían las nubes.
Alfredo Román Roca: Vivió vecina de esta ciudad.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y el.
Alfredo Román Roca: Mhm.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Domicilio en esta ciudad, por el señor los diputados.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y para lo tranquilo, esto no por.
Alfredo Román Roca: Que no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: El cuadrado de un poquito más 59.
Alfredo Román Roca: Entonces.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Tres, 2, 59 de la ley 600 urgente
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: mediante providencia de un poco a 220 se observó no, no, y tanto
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: de domicilio real de la parte demandante.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm, Puesto que el mismo era inextracto, sí.
Alfredo Román Roca: La parte de mandarte. A través de esto.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Abogado y acostumbrado a la vez.
Alfredo Román Roca: Aquí. No.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: A la.
Alfredo Román Roca: Los años de gloria.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Como si no.
Alfredo Román Roca: En su.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Aplausos.
Alfredo Román Roca: Muy bien.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De los.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: A través de su abogado y mediante Memorial.
Alfredo Román Roca: Cumple con observado y límites.
Alfredo Román Roca: La demandante, no no en la calle.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De la rosa. 261 del barrio en conjunto de esta ciudad como prueba a futuro.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y en.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No, no, aviso de colganza, sí de agua a ver.
Alfredo Román Roca: Se de.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Iluminación.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Sin embargo.
Alfredo Román Roca: Lo en la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y a la.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: A.
Alfredo Román Roca: Por eso.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Misma señala que tiene su domicilio.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm en 5, que es lo que digo y.
Alfredo Román Roca: Por otro lado.
Alfredo Román Roca: Mhm.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Sí, Sí.
Alfredo Román Roca: A los.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En su.
Alfredo Román Roca: A la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: A a.
Alfredo Román Roca: A de.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Que conforme se tiene providencia.
Alfredo Román Roca: A los.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y no, y en fecha 10 de noviembre, Mhm, para un día 19 de noviembre
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: y se ordenó los dispositivos para la Gestora del Órgano.
Alfredo Román Roca: Claro, como también a ser tramitado.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En la.
Alfredo Román Roca: Ciudad, reprochar.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Un A, muchas gracias y a.
Alfredo Román Roca: Al juzgado de turno.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: El público.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y a.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Línea de.
Alfredo Román Roca: Las motos.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Esto, considerando de que el tema claro se encuentra repetido.
Alfredo Román Roca: Que es.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En el Centro, el Avra y en la Audiencia Nacional.
Alfredo Román Roca: A la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Tal como han presenciado.
Alfredo Román Roca: Yo no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: La parte.
Alfredo Román Roca: Demandante.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Su traductor.
Alfredo Román Roca: Tubo, abogado.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: El demandado y el abogado, el demandado y a.
Alfredo Román Roca: El de.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En la.
Alfredo Román Roca: No un.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Gusta conectar.
Alfredo Román Roca: Lado, a las.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Bien, no, no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Por otro lado, el abogado de la parte demandante
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: indicó de que ha sido la Convención, incluida.
Alfredo Román Roca: A la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm se ha trasladado en demandar a la sala de audiencia de dichos centros penitenciario.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Sin embargo, de varios directos fallidos
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: de la segunda porque se pueda conectar.
Alfredo Román Roca: Claro.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No se ha podido, sí, aplausos y y también junto a los a los.
Alfredo Román Roca: Es de.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Ministerio de Seguridad.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: el tintero de las partes.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y tanto en el tema del órgano social
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: como código de la familia establecida con meridiana claridad.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Gracias por buscando la
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: competencia de los jueces.
Alfredo Román Roca: En este caso me refiero a no, no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Se encuentra establecido en el capítulo 11.
Alfredo Román Roca: A un y.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Opción que se llama esa potestad que tiene el estado de administrar justicia. Y Mhm
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: y hermana del pueblo boliviano especial.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y un.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Unidades nutricionales del órgano judicial.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y aquí.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Número 2: enseñaras sobre la y también
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: escribe en la facultad que tiene una magistrada o magistrado.
Alfredo Román Roca: Un volcán.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: O no es.
Alfredo Román Roca: Es muy.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Donde, en unos determinados.
Alfredo Román Roca: Todo lo y la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En nuestra relación.
Alfredo Román Roca: Una cabeza.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el artículo. 200.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Dos 1 020
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: perdón. En el artículo 222.
Alfredo Román Roca: En el.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y en.
Alfredo Román Roca: A la dirección y competencia por materia.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y territorios, y si Mhm, casa de la
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: también el artículo, 223 de.
Alfredo Román Roca: A y.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Parece 100 Tres: no tenía.
Alfredo Román Roca: Grande.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Era competente autoridad judicial.
Alfredo Román Roca: A veces.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De la residencia habitual de o de la Presidencia habitual de la o el del mandado versión de.
Alfredo Román Roca: A la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Demandantes.
Alfredo Román Roca: Mhm.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Esto es directamente 122 de la constitución política de Estado determinada.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: un nulo. Los actos de la persona.
Alfredo Román Roca: No, no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Que susto y funciones, que son el.
Alfredo Román Roca: Entre a.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Todo, de.
Alfredo Román Roca: Que quiero.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De comunicación.
Alfredo Román Roca: A un.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: El de.
Alfredo Román Roca: La que no emanen de la ley.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Relación al artículo 180 de la constitución política.
Alfredo Román Roca: Para de la está bien.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Dice la mujer?
Alfredo Román Roca: Ordinaria.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Principios.
Alfredo Román Roca: A de.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En su.
Alfredo Román Roca: Otro. No.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Transparencia.
Alfredo Román Roca: Realidad, la de la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y y.
Alfredo Román Roca: De la materia.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Al respecto.
Alfredo Román Roca: La verdad, a.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En el se tiene que.
Alfredo Román Roca: La audiencia.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm Ornamental, de que.
Alfredo Román Roca: Mhm.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: No referiré.
Alfredo Román Roca: En este municipio de si no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y no 3 cuartos terminado, que pertenece al municipio de Sana Cruz.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: también haciendo judicial, en el cual todos los y por derecho a la.
Alfredo Román Roca: Va a ganar.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: La demandante. Me corresponde acudir a.
Alfredo Román Roca: Lo que.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Estirar como lugar más próximo.
Alfredo Román Roca: De los.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Sí.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y lo considerando A.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Ciencias integral, y no podemos encarecer.
Alfredo Román Roca: La se.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Desde 4 cañadas a las pantallas, el espíritu.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y con el.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y de tenga su propio reflejo.
Alfredo Román Roca: Una vez más en.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Herrera.
Alfredo Román Roca: Inmediata, el y.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Claro.
Alfredo Román Roca: Oportuna. Podemos comer.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Comando han ser atendidos por lo que es.
Alfredo Román Roca: En la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Es por eso que el concepto de que el proceso de la.
Alfredo Román Roca: De la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: De los.
Alfredo Román Roca: La 11.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: La competencia del niño.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Si la demanda anterior fue atendida
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: en el lugar donde vive su domicilio real
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: por la actualidad policial que hay.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Tienes este municipio.
Alfredo Román Roca: Sí.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Por tanto, sí sí es sí
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: realizar una obra, revisión al proceso.
Alfredo Román Roca: Libro de holograma.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y las normas de dicha.
Alfredo Román Roca: No, no.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Responde que de.
Alfredo Román Roca: Competencia y.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: André librado 2 000.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y a tiene municipio de 4.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Claro, con la presentación.
Alfredo Román Roca: A lo que.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y la.
Alfredo Román Roca: Que demandante.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Por su abogado y el abogado del tema.
Alfredo Román Roca: Sí, Sí.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Hombre: ¿Cómo murió la audiencia?
Alfredo Román Roca: Claro.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Nosotros.
Alfredo Román Roca: En casa 24 h 11 de la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Sería a no.
Alfredo Román Roca: En las de.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Cuatro horas por secundaria con el oficio de estilo en el.
Alfredo Román Roca: Cliente a dicho municipio, algo que.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: En el.
Alfredo Román Roca: Era demandante de manera.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Hablen en cuanto a su pretensión de la.
Alfredo Román Roca: Autoridad.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Judiciales.
Alfredo Román Roca: Y en.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Y a no sabemos si la próxima.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Entonces, si no les sale oneroso venir hasta, acá por desgracia pueden retirarse
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: enseguida para que me firme en la calle.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Mhm.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: A la.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: por favor, haga cosas diligencias.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Un número de teléfono sí sabe el doctor solamente que no ha podido
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: darme el número de su su cliente
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: es lo único. No hay más. Todo después era eso más el como la anterior audiencia, el demandado nomás, tenía que conectarse.
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: Ahora lo que quiero es a
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: que, sin embargo, que podemos averiguar el juzgado doctor
SECRETARIO JUZGADO 7 FAMILIA -JPF7: ha hay un este, hay un que se llamará.